[Music]
from an undisclosed location highland
hills it's time once again the long shot
Nate just seein turn ha America the
Great British Bake Off and specialist
Jack occation and now please welcome the
host of the long shots on sunrise thank
you thank you thank you good afternoon
good evening good morning good night
good day good dusk good desk welcome to
the long shot it is a podcast to which
you are listening i am your host my name
is sean connery with me today on the pot
podcast the one and only Joey egner hey
everybody amber Kenny and of course
Jamie planet acadeca ha ha this is that
unless super energy right our special
guest today Jackie Kashian is here been
here before and has agreed to come back
new group almost the three core yeah
that's right now before we even get
started we have some very exciting
developments to talk about which is this
is episode we're about to record episode
299 what da [__] in two hours ago we
will have recorded episode 301 yes right
next week live we are going to record
episode three hundred and we are
inviting anybody who wants to come
anybody who wants to come whether or not
their phantom podcast whether or not
they live in Los Angeles they want to
fly in as Jamie said in the commercial
rain and a variety ah but if you want to
come to the show email Jamie at Jamie at
Jamie at Jamie
no the emails Jamie at Jenna flag com I
got lost from ya please write that your
autobiography got lost in the ass Jamie
at Jamie flame calm and we only have to
hope that Jamie does not still have his
away message on which when we first
started pitching the 300th episode
people were emailing and getting back hi
I'm taking some time off from email
right now yeah I sound like an email
Jason hi there I love you all hi there
partner that is a funny little kind of
like print it's almost like a prank
response yeah send us an email I'm not
looking at it I turned it off with the
first five people of East London did get
that and I went and then we had one more
so they're sick the first might be the
bottom people that cared the mode are
the ones we [__] with I got a little
gift yeah souvenir hail from JP flam
alright so as we do on every episode why
don't we start today's episode with a
segment that we like to call checking in
and because it is our second episode of
the day why don't we start with Jamie
and then go do it um I got a text from
Andrew yeah while I was the hardest
introduced to the show at the last
episode saying don't kind of blow your
wad odd because i was talking a lot of
different things not it I don't think
that's an appropriate text don't blow
your wad I give it we will get it
together yeah don't come I was such a
locking last email babies all faithful
you ever hear that Woody Allen routine
where he's thinking about baseball
during sex no does it does that it's
like he gave on get well he could know
he gets obsessed with like why is he
doing that he should not be you know
don't run on
he gets way too into it it's very funny
go ahead Jamie um well a couple things
maybe I last I briefly mentioned in 301
you will briefly measure that Mary I
will convicted time forever sometime in
the last three hours but thursday night
I went out and it was the first night
going out not just going out but going
to multiple places so I 530 once i went
to the ecv sunset for the first time
since it opened five years ago I don't
even know that events like to go was it
really yeah I thought it was longer but
I'm and was got lost and now huge this
place was in the cafe which Andrews like
we should work at the cafe one day I was
like I pictured a little [__] and as
I walked in there's like hundreds of
people milling about the complaint good
5 o'clocks on and they asked you for
seven dollars for a cup of coffee yes
yeah I'm stopped yet yeah and then saw
my friend do a musical that was just
phenomenal and then went straight to
their to my friends he had a record
release party at a studio and while i
was walking there i get here Jamie flam
and it's the jazz trumpet player from
the van gem show that he's doing ab ella
fitzgerald tribute show at this wine bar
on Hollywood so I popped in there and
check that out knows a school scene and
then I went to the distant eater where
was machine project which is an art
galleries having this big opening to
celebrate their thing I was doing all
these things right and I love that
feeling of I'm about town being in the
world and I haven't had that in years
right and it's the difference between
going out knowing like okay I have to go
to this one thing is show or something
and then a night where you're like
literally it's like where will the night
take me like I'll just kind of keep
going and and stuff kept popping up for
you to do I just picture Jamie walking
into each of these places in this big
crowd of paparazzi outside like that's
five escribe O'Hara class
how are you say it is easy but are you
gonna go see the Vista later I had two
other things to do that Connie climbs on
his way over the best to get over that
quick my nights that began where you
didn't know they were going always ended
up with me sitting at this one bar just
doing shots and talking about politics
this episode they ended almost third bar
listener possible hairy chick going down
because you're looking to be depressed
yes that's a guy you harry chapin a song
about about the death of a baby diet
unos that was it was that but there was
the baby who died of starvation did you
ever further that one scene it was your
like Jesus Christ the seven days are
over really go together but it has like
a real snappy tune the beats were good
night Jason was he cat's in the cradle
yeah well exactly with us taxi yeah sure
what thirty thousand pounds over 30,000
pounds of eating bananas sure sure uh-uh
fun night funny but also yourself
believe how did it I wit and how did
that night end mr. Brian mr. Quan give
us a profile now give us a smile that's
right mr. pile in my car with Jason be
sure who I one of my best friends okay
as my discussed last week a dude just
talking about life for a couple hours
but here's what I think an X Factor I
don't want to you today with the water
is he your mom good enough doctor I
haven't had a drink of alcohol and 31 or
today was I didn't drink in March and
April but i granted something about
that's fine when I'm gonna drinking
right okay and I don't know we'll get to
that I probably will drink again at some
point but I'm the difference of when I'm
in a drinking phase I just how what a
filter that puts on how about planned
and how much of a damper listed on my
social life especially in the last year
the improv just like it's a big reason
why stay in the neighborhood like but
like when I'm not drinking just like i
can i'm driving to different places and
I'm
scootin about and how much more fun that
is and I'm it's time any truth to the
rumor you might have a drink tonight I
might later yeah we can I shot of you on
your scooter I just imagined you
scooting around up a little like I love
these guys by the way I won't come
around you guys want to go out on this
we could hit the town anyways that that
that was great last night I watched the
movie lala land anyone see that you
haven't won the oscar for best picture
did it no it didn't it almost did for a
minute but it did but then it didn't had
such mixed reviews by people i know
who's polarizing was very polarizing and
ong is a big component me seen it I
believe and I you know what I liked it I
didn't need all the music but it was
refined but it is also like what's
article but like everything now no good
i can take a leave some 10 her get her
leave it yeah it was oddly not oddly
just like it's about a guy that would
follow his dream to open a club that has
a jazzy and magical enchanting vibes in
Los Angeles and I couldn't help but feel
a parallel was that whole thing and like
it was a celebration of Los Angeles and
which is why it did so well at the
academy cuz it all of our stories I
thought I did it the stories like in a
way that could have been much more
cliche like oh could have been oh it
could have been more question what it
had so it had some good I thought that
you thought I thought that did didn't I
guess somebody broke so i used it as a
coaster I didn't want it I gave mine
away in this era hey there is something
annoying about like so it's about
actresses and actors in LA and I've
never been my thing but I never in my
bag a measure of my bag wigs
my guys will understand that too we
that's a callback to a joke into it you
may not give me that like this but you
know well there you go back to the
future what day was I was all right it
was alright mr. playa alright didn't at
did I go all right oh I supposed to do
much of yesterday and what happened I
went did you do mushrooms at all in
March no okay and that's what led to
lala land and I should have started at
the beginning of the story but I'm you
still can you're right weird time travel
um a friend of mine and I many of ours
was like let's do mushrooms like that's
great I'm at a point in my life where I
think I need to have this brain
degeneration be true no okay and we went
to the play went to Griffith by the way
Saturday night and so getting to
Griffith the observatories already can
be kind of crazy with traffic but I it
was insane it was like in traffic up in
those hills and after seeing all I was
like I bet the part of this is lala land
traffic like if tourists saw this big
movie now Griffith Observatory is even
more about right because it was soon all
right I really do think that it makes it
even a more musty place but I'm gonna go
you can't so is anyone selling I was
like if that's true I hope that there's
hand trucks selling never duel [__]
grandfather was selling popcorn on the
way up which you guys will understand in
two weeks on volume feel evil so core
game lalala
for Griffith Park traps are key and also
so good for the park lads we were
driving up or like we don't know you
can't park anywhere because the after
sunset so like that affects our ability
to do a drug that might inhibit e to
drive away putting ability right and so
we drove to the other side of Griffith
Park and then by that point it was it
was just for Amber some reason such an
Amber thing where I always look at her
first one I am talking and do something
weird amber am i okay and it's just
laughing it's kind of a disarms the
whole situation oh wow you guys we're
doing this podcast at 7i 307 this is the
two hundred waters our story Jamie the
friendship that is built around this I
remember I think I did it for the first
time seven years ago we were one of our
first yeah yeah yeah so it's beautiful
but how some things have changed in some
ever looking for like amber you get my
back right even early on I had my back
so we got to the other side and it was
getting cold and we didn't really know
where we were and the friend I think
could made a good executive decision
because I was already like in my head
like I don't know if I should be doing
this which is never a good thing before
you doing good mine and I think really
cold I was like I'm gonna be cold and
being cold on a country like that's like
never good but I also was like well if
everyone's gonna do it I guess I'm gonna
do it yeah you always one other person a
great we met one other friend of mine
there so there's three O's and so he
made that he's like I'm not feeling it I
don't I don't think I think I mean he
called the game and he's like we can you
bust out again you're gonna get that
gotta stop crush the mud scratch but it
was like well we can go back to your
place and just do them they're not like
now I need nature if I'm going to do
this I need to be communing with nature
and so things like well we can go watch
lala land on the projector of my place
and so we did that and so I liked how it
organically because we live in a movie
server no you just owns a 35-millimeter
camera and the copy of lala land
it was the kind where every 17 minutes
would say on the bottom like this is it
I'm so screen out of the screener pretty
guys but he has a project like a digital
project as we watch there we go thank
you think you're helping I was like
change real change real no not happening
none of that's an issue okay I'm over
here just saw the black dot in the upper
right corner we got a chain around that
is a prominent plot point of an episode
of Columbo oh really where the murderer
has to like do it during the real change
and that's the alibi haha that's also in
glorious battle ax ya bastards right
wait a minute can I just ask you one
more thing Denton we just happen that
happen recently was that an episode last
week well yeah we've talked about it
last week that's great you'll find that
out last week right right if you've been
listening in order this one should head
home that's good every census we will
talk about where don't think that happen
oh oh this quick call because Jackie
being here reminded me of being at UCB
and and just running into people the
last week just being around and seeing
the comedians and and feeling the fun
about it not a dread now that i read it
wasn't like the last several months of
like being that i need a thought
godfather yeah yeah they eliminate all
that it was just like these are people
that are i'm talking to you're my friend
and because whenever i talk to jackie
was always there's something a lot of
pressure a lot of pressure such occasion
yes
when when you get me up hafsa the lab
what if I just didn't I earring I'll
come in Joe kisan can you help me out
yeah I'm nobody's more focused on their
career than that I think that we've all
established then it's been really nice
just being out and seeing people in like
there's no underlying there's no
pressure yeah you can't get them spot
you have nothing to diamond bearing down
for anybody you just want to watch them
till jokes if they're gonna be telling
jokes yeah but also just I like comedy i
forgot that i really like comedy and
scene shows and good although i've seen
one show it was a musical but anyway
you're writing a musical not letting
musical you know that's one last thing
was I actually going to law and there's
that like it's like there's so many
layers of pressure when you're talking
to people and it's like what are you
doing what are you doing what are you
what are you up to right now yeah that
sucks that's [__] Los Angeles man
it's the worst thing where nobody has
and I find myself doing it too and I
hate myself every time I do it where I
run into somebody I'm like what he been
up to you know and then yeah especially
if they just had a special on that
slider said and you're like so what's
next but if you're like oh my [__]
god can I kill you yeah and the tough
thing is it's almost the default
question because you don't want to ask
just the usual how are you yeah because
we own the world that's annoying nobody
does say that what they're really saying
is what doing what do you work it out
didn't times that I've asked how are you
meaning how are you right and they start
listing their resume and that's another
thing that I do that I'd really so for
where something is how are you and I'm
like well I'm you know mr. pickles
finished up here and I'm working on a
couple scripts that I got you know
good at Microsoft Word what have I
become what is everyone did we talked
about this last time now I'm everyday
job boob but I talk about the different
layers the I'd probably talk about with
every episode of brain filters in every
conversation but like the meaning of
what everything but I realized how often
like I when someone asks how I HAP I
just started to talk about that and I
just filtered that out I'm sorta bird so
i don't know if i am repeating this but
like I feel like they need to apologize
well it's been kind of a rough patch and
yeah I haven't done much since leaving
The Improv and blah blah blah i'm like i
like i don't have to say all that
fighting you should start just being
like I'm killing it ya know it's like I
put it all the way that is oh yeah right
no I mean I'm not even killing the
people that are and I'm saying they're
successful now but 10 years ago when
they weren't successful that was the
attitude right people always had was
like I'm [__] nailed it dude I got
this pound on lockdown I got four irons
in the fire there already i feels like
well I should be working harder on my
katoya I still have it foul my pilot
yeah like I'm not good i'm just not good
I don't hang out acting I'm doing
stand-up I'm excited to take voice
lessons and i think i'm going to become
a dog whisperer guys just just for my
free time I'm not a sir just answering
wish yeah like hobbies like so what do
you been up to got into crochet okay oh
my god well when somebody and people
have been I've had a bad cold and it
makes me feel like hey middle-aged white
lady don't talk about your health nobody
figured was here that but I'm not a bad
cold you guys dressed for 16 days into
this thing and it was it's an epically
law I am for the first time I had to
cancel work and a Binford got me a bit
part on her show that I could not do ah
and kill Martin was like nobody knows
what you sound like fun [__] go and I
was like stop talking my throat feels
like shards of glass I hate you
so that's an she was my dad of course
tell you what if somebody drew a
caricature of how my life was going
right now there'd be a huge pair of
balls on there because I am [__] kill
ya dog with sunglass well you don't want
to hear that guy right or girl what
those people they feel like I feel like
they win yes feel like that that is that
is safe word the presidency mother's
last yeah guy Jamey dude so just
realizing like I don't have to say like
what am i doing it I'm writing a musical
and that's great and you're living or I
don't understand it but like I don't
have to preface everything with all the
stuff going on in my own brain right
justify my existence when it depends on
the relationship you have with the
person how vulnerable you are to them I
think I think I'm just gonna roll with
everybody but here's another aspect of
that and I Haiti popping on the fact
that everybody should be telling
everybody else how they're killing it
all the time people don't like
perception you people people personal
people don't care yeah about how you
feel like they don't give a [__] who you
have so is and they don't want to hear
about it and they don't want to think of
it when they don't want to be reminded
of their self-doubt rightly and so what
they want to hear is a flexion of what
they want to feel about themselves which
is like it's all good baby it's all good
you know which is [__] annoying
because I'm the same way you are which
is like I feel like I have to be honest
with people and people don't want you to
be they do not want you to be honest I
just want to say as I copy it unless
you're listening to our podcast right
now those are the people who actually
about to finish up there are some people
who do and they live in to the club sure
that yeah podcast listeners by default
are like okay I have self-doubt hey I
have a spiral of that how are you
handling them it's a new podcasts are
good
they're really good one is out that way
every week you guys come back into
another podcast you like yes what didn't
happen i had self-doubt and I didn't cut
myself we all win and I didn't yeah I'm
just so true so that's what that's the
greatest total in your podcast totally I
should keep it we're talking to industry
laughs are you killing killing it
another thing I like doing and it hasn't
worked out it's not like a successful
thing some people say like what have you
been up to I go same ol same ol and it's
like they have to figure out what you
put it on them I hate this was like
maybe a year and a half ago I taped a
set for a thing and my agent was there
and I did not feel good about how my set
when I knew it didn't go well and I came
offstage he was like great job and I was
[__] awesome and I was like ah it
really didn't feel good like and he did
not want to hear that yeah yeah just did
not want to hear it yeah because he
doesn't want to work with somebody that
doesn't feel like I'm great you know
every time I go on stage I'm destroying
it yeah yeah oh my god uh what else
Jamie Maddie that's good here you killed
it I killed it that was what that second
ever done I just killed it on long shot
textin better than I ever have I'm
pretty excited for the next segment of
the shadow wagner all right
right all right I want to talk about
something that happened in the time that
I've not been here and I've been looking
for I'm work my mind is falling apart
right now because I camera when you work
now when he happily hasn't been here I
have not been here for a while a week
yes right right but I was bent back
before and now here and I've been
looking for work and a friend of mine
reached out to me and this is a guy met
on a Latino music awards show that I did
like seven years ago and I had the
opportunity to meet this guy who's a
sketch comedy writer from Mexico so cool
I've never I've never met another comedy
right as if the bumblebee guy so that
the bumblebee guy but he did write for a
local talk show that's called el
platanito which actually Paula Tompkins
is pinned on and it's hosted by a clown
it's a talk show hosted by a clown
basically and it's like who's looking
the bad he doesn't want to be on that
died it really is balanced with a
importantly Mexican clown yeah yeah I'll
make up in a red now okay with the wig
and everything right so by the way you
can't go on youtube and see this clown
turn and ask question to public oh you
can include on a [__] torture said I
would be googling that is really book is
it translated or how does that uh he
would kind of uh he would spawn split ho
banish well the host was you know
bilingual to the hose would talk to him
and in English and then I think and then
he would answer them the host kind of
translate Paul's responsible in Spanish
was interesting anyway I met this guy
this comedy writer his name is in hockey
and in Yankee texted me and was like hey
I think I have a possible job
opportunity can you meet this friday yes
it can great so then text me he's like
we're going to be meeting at the outback
in Glendale so I'm like oh my damn never
been more excited for a meeting of my
life outback make a run for the border
oh no that's Taco Bell
oh it feels like the outback oh yes
trillion border make a swim the ocean so
I go I go and I'm thinking that it's
going to be me my friend anaki and one I
I just imagine like one other person and
like what did they look like I thought
of a man male privilege excite he looked
like Paula Thompson I get there and
there's seven people it's like month so
it's much prettier than I thought of yet
they and they're also get this sitting
around this table Meza and him and I
realized that it's going to be so it's
kind of a pitch and a formal pitch
meeting brainstorm a sailing over a
bloomin onion / wow I thought so when
nobody ordered a bloomin onion right I
thought I was right about yeah but how
do you gotta get them they got like the
nachos place that's like cold in two
minutes and my bull shot a couple
[__] on that one you don't go to
outback better than Australian nachos
right known for that so um I get to
another jalapeno on the nachos Mike and
it's the better like accomplished liar
you want that um producers and what
turns out to be the coffee what it was
its yeah yeah cuz I I I was basically
kind of dropping into this one I thought
it was going to be more like a one on
one thing and I think it should be
parachuting in glendale and i sit down
and the coolest thing about that night
was that basically it it was a two hour
meeting in Spanish which I've never I've
never had that experience of actually
being part of a creative discussion in
another language but I do speak Spanish
so I I understood everything and then I
was like throwing my two cents in in
Spanish and like trying go to get
nervous about it
but it I was I was like the one I
definitely was the one white guy even
I'm not really white but I was the one
white guy and the cast the cast that
they were thinking about for this pilot
was there and then a coupling kind of
like management and ate some agents and
and so the best thing was like because I
I don't hear I mean unless something
like doing my laundry and like watching
Univision or something I hear a lot of
Spanish but being able to pick up slang
your context is really funny and like
listening to them talk about you'll get
old sketch going biblioteca in Rumania
yet at one point the what the pilot they
were describing is but this kind of a
kind of a he's like an agent who mostly
has Latino clients but he's trying to
like get higher up in the biz and he
asked these two actresses who are his
roommates who's always trying to get
work for so they can pay the rent and at
one point I'm we're talking about the
dynamics of the characters oh I'm like
yeah maybe it's a little bit like
Three's Company kind of thin air like
reporters there were these two women who
are the actresses are gonna be the show
could we're born dido and one so they're
like what is it what is the show is an
Eskimo homosexually goal bigger ah que
bueno
I can have it's the guy from 8 simple
rules oh it was a pedestal a lot of fun
it just felt it was just cool to have
that opportunity to use my period of
mind but speaking Spanish and still try
to you know that's me actually yeah yeah
and I haven't heard from them since but
but it was basing one of those things
maybe they were waiting for you to order
the glowing onion cheese la ventana esta
abierto y cuando tengo un reloj I wonder
if the windows open WOD doesn't have a
watch I wonder if every time you're
invited to like I've been invited to
weird lunches were it felt like I was
like what is this yeah we're and then
like 52 minutes in you find out that
they want to do something with you
instead of I'm like I want to play
Beyonce's weird white ant you have an
idea where the show's entirely about me
and I'm like I don't and so I've ruined
it right because a lot much later on was
sitting they don't want to know that you
don't can't read their mind and you are
in a certain that your valid yeah I
don't know I don't know if I'm right for
this part yes like here sometimes like
quickly you want me to be this and I
would have to so I should you're like I
am NOT a hero of the store I am God the
year of the story so I should go into
every meeting thinking oh I am clearly
new [__] and you're gonna want to oh
this isn't about me and then somehow
shoehorn my way into it and make it
about me it's such a weird thing and I
yea sorry go ahead i was ready i think
in this case what was nice with the kind
of low stakes in that way it was like I
was just kind of brought in so it's
sometimes it's nice when you know the
focus isn't on you at all cuz I was
coming into that like Oh job possible
job the end
turning along Elmo right and then I
actually got to just be the guy that SAT
back and listened a lot and then I you
know I throw out a couple things by just
listen one because it's actually it was
really interesting because just to get a
peek into a completely different
partnership in the switches these
producers want to do a style of comedy
that isn't common on spanish TV they
wanted to do something grounded and more
real and less broad and they were
setting up this story of this agent in
the roommates and and what they wanted
the show to be about was Latino
performers actors actresses who come to
LA to try to get crossover success and
have to basically start from square one
and the two actresses that they were
talking to they both done like
afterwards I immediately googled them
because I was like who were these people
they both done like 15 telenovelas in
Mexico they're huge right now nobody
knows right and and so a lot of the
meeting was just them telling stories of
what it's like for them to be trying to
bury working actors in Hollywood were
like they go to you know go go to some
big Hollywood party and no nobody knows
them except all the help at the mansion
Wow and they all want to get to scaling
Fanny because they were all watching
little civility yeah and and just like
how they mean it's neat but it yeah and
and you know and how sometimes like
they're not there you know they're not
led on to the lie you know like all
these things is like you know oh they
could have taken at my my bosom buddies
meets Chico and the man if they want me
to Latino women who moved to Los Angeles
but they got to live at the Y so they
gotta dress like guys
outback reservations are not bad they
can have that and then the I don't know
there's some weird a job la playa hace
frio pero Cristobal tiene dos patas the
beach this is a very cool cool but was
who was the crystal ball first of all
and it does about to help to shape
definitely coming to the next two shoes
I like that this guy's good hi my niece
is both like did her one of them is now
in her like eighth year of Chinese
immersion but they both point we're in
Spanish Immersion program and it so they
started speaking Spanish pretty early on
and it would drive them up the [__]
wall when I would with any with us to
that really much of it it's grown day
what are you talking about with that boy
boys yeah oh yeah because that was
seeing what about a fun of that like
record I got ya in high school they had
those demonstration tapes I think they
were even tapes at that point like
cassette tape and that was how they
would say it like I'll say calor hace
calor they always fail you swore like
they're giving instructions on writing
at Disneyland right yes I would always
say it like that so there you go maybe
I'll work on that one day we'll see yeah
that would be fun help yeah amber
checking in yeah I have recently been
going to a new dance class and it's just
because it's where it works for my
schedule the night that I'm free and I
I've learned with time that if I don't
take a dance class at least once a week
I'm not okay like mentally and really so
I'm good thing to know
just like I oh I need exercise like I
kind of jam any kind of food you taking
all the dance me I got it why haven't
you been on the door for us what the
[__] is happening oh hey glasses already
but to that point this tuesday night is
when I tend to be available to take a
dance class and it isn't my favorite
like I have my favorite classes and I
haven't been able this is not the one
you like yes it's a sad story poor me I
what's wrong with this was a spy yeah
I'll start from the beginning I actually
like it out it's gonna we're gonna go on
a journey but it's called groups
strapped in it's called groove3 and I've
always avoided it because 01 and cruise
you want to suck right well and if you
would miss one how would you catch up I
think you are these characters group 3
by the way came out in 1989 everybody
wore high top was actually a line it's a
dollar more because here's the bad part
there's a live DJ I know it was great is
he the kind of DJ that they would have
at like a wedding where he's like all
right let's get out there on the dance
floor everybody mother would not really
yes he is the live DJ also the person
leading no ethics that's why I think
it's a dollar more okay there is a dance
teacher and how many people are in this
class like 60 it's oh so it's worth 60
bucks to this person to show up um and
it's just for now it just by V as it
just seemed a little juju Josh or
something thank you you want more
serious gravitas to your daddy one I
prefer it today I mean there's a lot of
that come down obviously to the song
selection or the music being played well
I think the fact that it's called group
3 group 3 already right and that there's
a DJ like um DJ's our people one of my
best friends at the DJ but there's a
sweeping shape here
let's talk about them if there isn't DJ
I don't ok right they're not always for
you it's yeah what's another situation
with the DJ like a club yeah yeah so the
club yeah the club vibe can you play
build me up buttercup that's my
impression of every person talking to a
DJ ever so I go to the first class 3
winging out nowhere where I've never
seen in the key thing I think that might
kill the vibe right now that's good I
just really like something about me so I
go to the class and there's a ton of
people also you wear shoes Wow correct I
usually am before you wear zapatos dos
girl thos where go stealing his wife
it's like a sneaker it felt also by the
ads like more like just like a cardio
class which is what some people want but
I want a dance class I want to express
myself through my thick oh my god in a
[__] pig oh good about taking up
embroidery and putting that on a pillow
I mean a really good it's a good one oh
wait I after this I need to know what
other what defines a class that that
expresses like do you ever take like
ballroom dance or swing or I haven't or
salsa I've taken a salsa and then I i
prefer looks awesome the dance or the
sausages what's in the first of all so
what what's Kim first is this also did
for the salsa dance I'll this morning
patient important that means what yes
I'm you saw something in any way where
are your shoes you show up there's a lot
of humans a ton of people yeah thank you
like I got to be here another
there was not coming back for at least
eight years expressive avant-garde dance
class ahead of that so they have to
clear out and the DJ has to set up so
there's like a little bit of just
milling about time and everyone is
standing in the class and a lot of
people know each other you can tell well
that's what I leave well it gets worse
oh good teacher comes in and he comes
like beeline right to me but hey I'm Ben
I don't think I've seen you before with
that energy and I was like I'm amber
this is he looked is your first class I
was like yeah he's like you're gonna be
able to keep up just watch me look like
yeah I'm gonna be fine and he's like had
to hear about the class anyway so like
okay maybe he just does this then he
proceeded to go to each person in the
room and hug them and ask them about
their life and I was like this church
because then we did like a little bit of
a warm-up and he's like all right
everybody say hi to three people you
don't know and I was like this is not
the usual dance class this is not the
usual dance execution ya know also what
it was rather than church one oh my god
say hi to the people make it using peace
and the light with you but that's
different and also with you that like
Christian churches that I went to with
friends in high school we're very like
phony-baloney friendly that's the vibe
it felt like we're like 12 friend here
and what are we I don't know talking
religion by the way but and the class
itself is it's actually really fun and
you sweat your ass off so I keep going
back so what's going on with the podcast
a first no I don't I don't eat you like
nothing ever exhume it mostly drives
them insane to do you like how was your
week I was like it's Tuesday man I
you're talking about to that energy
because there's a guy just started
working at the starbucks up here who has
that energy when you go up to the cat
her and I just don't really didn't want
to deal with it yeah you know I did it
he's ok he's an instructor of a workout
so you need to have you can't come in
low energy so you don't have to put it
on what but it feels like there's a
middle ground like you don't be that
aggressive but I also feel like when
you're a guy at Starbucks like deep hey
take take your cue from how in game I am
with you hmm you know right you're not
an amateur question doors open tourism
what is the what was the music and what
are the moods ok this dance class great
question thank you very much I had so I
thought I'd hate the DJ aspect it ended
up being a selling point because it's
all like popular music from the 90 s
basically with like a techno beat
because they have to keep the same
rhythm the music never goes out so
you're doing the same dance and
different songs are happening basically
so it has to stay the same rhythm that's
the power yay um so it's fun and I it's
a houseful what are you doing oh you
know Novak arena eat chicken dance
naples happening a lot of good wood is
like a lot okay um and there are people
in there who are very good at office so
it's like the boogie Woogie Bugle Boy of
Company B this is the heck miss back I
couldn't get that song out of my head
last night it randomly why is that a
theme in my life test with The Andrews
Sisters I don't know it's like Adam a
bubbler your Senators grant gravity is
pretty low like if your feet are planted
in your knees are bent and it's like
it's fast and you're jamming left and
right yeah yeah all right just and but
he'll like give you high fives in the
middle and I would like glue and now I'm
like it just kind of like it doesn't
welcome to know I yeah
exactly like he got you I you know she
knows there's worse church no worries
exactly it's the least harmful church of
all time and but a lot of people talk to
each other do they have social turn
aftereing those dances no just like like
after as soon as the class is done I'm
like cartwheeling out the door any [__]
did you see please do that and people
are just like so like they're just like
in circles talking and I wonder if maybe
I should be more open to connecting with
people but I don't want you yeah I'm
with you a hundred percent but I feel
like you're different than I am so it
might be okay no but but I think the
important thing is that like you know
the people that you do connect with
because I think we mostly do that in the
in the comedy scene you know like that's
the environment that we're in but a lot
of times if it's an activity where you
just want to do the activity you're not
there for any content I'm not going to
make friends I think I like I know
there's other place to make friends yeah
because there's a common leave a like
minded individuals devil's advocate
argument to that is like hey why not be
open right in front like right I don't
have to make friends but i also don't
have to like put a few dress are any of
these people attractive emotionally to
you you're looking like oh well let that
woman seems like a nice enough human i
can probably be friends with her yeah
from a distance I think it is I think
that person is the person that turns to
you does that guy quickly or annoy you
or whatever the best usual better that's
the first step that's a good connection
the first you wanted dancing and Jesse
ever has people standing in a circle
going do you think that cartwheel girl
why she's such a [__] I also
standoffish I don't think it's so funny
and I make fun of my self in my head
because they'll be dead but he's like
you get in the front and I'm like oh me
like oh shiz I couldn't possibly and
then I
I'm social integration and core she's
really popping those boom cartwheeling
all around other people like such as
phony below in it like Oh inside just
false modesty I love it so yeah we'll
see if I go to church in this week
hahaha that's my chicken in Great Neck
that one is this tuesday at eight thirty
to ten and you're listening to the show
at the flip-flop come on down i gotta go
i really want to hey I haven't seen you
before and I would this kind of higher
percentage of men vendors classes I take
then we visit Mormon great and you're
perfect you know why don't you take a
dance class with a higher percentage of
man what's wrong with you I don't know I
record our way yeah it's like seems
doable but right you don't feel so alone
yeah well it's like those guys who went
into theater just to get laid there like
it's not okay yes that's why I wanted to
do it worked out great can't stop won't
stop so this leads me to Jackie now we
are doing this episode in a different
way than we usually do where we usually
start with checking in with just us and
then bring somebody else in for a second
segment but we're going to roll right
into that second segment because did you
not check in though yeah because well
sometimes i do sometimes I don't but
today because we're doing two episodes
oh right right if you feel checked in
you feel channel checked out no it just
feels like we're going way too long yeah
I want to keep you here for you long
sorry but uh yeah it's all you either
I'm in a no-win situation so we asked
anything that you wanted to talk about
and you had something right thing well I
was that it was
first of all before we even get in yes
because it's related i think in a
three-member it's not on this album know
what is you have a new give a new album
that just came out right new album just
came out happen hey hey Jackie how are
you every three years whether anyone
wants me to or not I put out a new album
you guys I'd it's called well I am NOT
the hero of this story and I'm holding
it for the camera zoom in on that she
really is just got the beauty so I
brought a hard copy it's did a nice job
and this is what the actual heroism of
myself would look like was just means
torching the kind of soda anyway the
Acme I record them all in acme comedy
company in many animals yes my home club
and then it is it came out six weeks
after the election and so I had 12
minutes about my dad that I had to get
rid of it wasn't out I was going to do
an hour and now I had and it was
probably 15 minutes but whatever it was
it was I cut it out because two people
to too many came up and said hey your
dad kind of sounds like Trump and I was
like did you want to get punched in the
throat I love my father and and so Ike
but he has this kind of voice yeah he's
a Salesman he needs a pitch guy but one
of the great things about my father is a
shame he should not be president that's
what he knows how and it's one of the
great things about him and he's not a
creep he's a jackass which is much
different and none of my brother how I
know he's not a creep none of my
brothers are grapes okay because you can
look at ixnay a new day and whatever the
[__] their names are you can tell
they're creeps from here right I mean
they're [__] lb I wager like wash my
ya every time is too much puts pomade in
the 10 year old stops the freezing of a
creep so anyway I do it but only the 10
year olds I don't know it's like a prank
so the album is done better than any of
my previous albums it was an according
life I was using a better God is done
better yeah do I think this is my best
album mmm jury's still out I can't I
can't be the one wait I don't know
there you go they keep getting better
and I mean Jeff first one was great the
first line they've just gotten better
and better and better and then so but it
so the first 12 minutes is actually
political jokes and I've traditionally
never been a political comic but it was
six weeks after the election and I'd not
soon yeah it was impossible I felt I
felt like I'm alive right we're doing
this and if the world ends for some
reason my ego was like I'll get these
jokes up first anyway so that the
album's called another year on the story
and my dad actually just I talked to my
dad I sent him a copy yesterday today
and he said um hey I just called you to
tell you i got the album and i said okay
there's just long silence and he goes
I'm running for president and I said did
you listen to I why are you white hey
man and he goes twice I still got I'm
not doing my notes so that's what makes
twice but another wow we listen to it
you know well he wants it to be inducted
he was disappointed that the twelve were
exited out about him so he did say
because there's already probably 15
about him he said any album of yours it
is more than 25 minutes about me that's
my album that sound like fair enough
right what's the cut did you get notes
on your previous albums I've got notes
on every time I father have seen me in
every sense a placement that he
diagrammed after one show he was like
let's go get a cup of coffee I got some
things talk about oh my diagrams my act
it was love it was what kind of notes
are we talking well they're mostly and
he's never hears the anier irritating
thing about him is because he's been
doing sales for I don't know a hundred
years he's never wrong he's not wrong
it's irritating coming from this
horrible aluminum siding place and what
does that run
does it have I mean because I would
imagine maybe that he is a sense of
timing and clarity as far as that's
exactly information that's exactly where
he's a bad resource oh he's amazing what
are we still annoying it's still
annoying because he's my dad Anna and so
it's funny because people are like where
do you get your comedy from and I was
like I get my timing for my father but I
get my comedy from my stepmother I think
I get my sense of humor because she was
a lot she was a little [__] look you got
to set the hook walk away that's the
hook and walk away i must say no without
a number you guys know what a great
comedian do the setup walk off it wait
wait to see if any of the art follow you
away what's it is consistent advice to
me is that I talk too fast he's like you
don't let them laugh you don't let them
laugh I'm so funny because that really
is the sale thing yes you don't say
anything and you wait for the other
person to you right now let's let them
laugh and I have the same response they
can have the rest of their lives to last
12 minutes that I got some business I
don't know what you anyway so I so the
election happened and I was like I gotta
figure out how I could fix this because
I am a control freak and I'm handling
and it's the here she speed to anyway
yeah it's that's what we're living
through if you remember so speed to it's
like someone is running at you with a
knife for an hour eirick oh my God he's
got a knife and then you weed off and
have some popcorn they're like oh my God
he's still got a nice and there's
nothing I can't fix it and anyway so
Nick's grandfather cells popcorn by the
way two weeks ago about a month ago
there was month and a half maybe five
weeks there was a weekend my in-laws are
in town we're all sitting around I see
on the internet that there is an
immigration a nice setup on the big
street my my my my according to the
internet right by my house and I say to
my husband we
laundry did we need a dish detergent and
he goes now we do this now and I was
like yeah yeah I'm going to the grocery
store right now and he's like it's these
mother [__] and so I said there might
be nice setup with their advantage
Boulevard I'm gonna go check it out and
he's like gonna go look for trouble well
I'm gonna steal my mom's but I love you
call me if you need no I'm gonna go look
for laundry detergent ago in trouble
might find me did find me because I am
maroon anyway so there was no there was
no I son it was a either a shadow thing
or it was already down anyway I go to
the grocery store I'm coming out of the
grocery store and in front of me is an
old i push an old man you guys a
question old man I feel your ideas are
shut up okay sometimes you get to the
punch line to pass this is thats about
the punch line and write it down on this
place that is the error and here's what
happens I'm walking out of ralphs and
there's a rent captain and there's a guy
in front of me an eighty-year-old gotta
be 80 right Inez if that doesn't look
crazy doesn't look homeless you know
like two carries he's 80 khakis belt
polo shirts you need a French bread
right pretty high and yes a friend
refreshment but guys you know and so AB
can be one yet he starts yelling at the
red to cop and he says the N word and he
says the guys from Haiti and he caused
aids and that whoa he's and it went off
on this forever like it was like it was
literally like like from inside ralphs
to outside Ralphie still shouting stuff
at this guy and at first you know I was
like hell trying to figure out even what
great in it if it had happened ten years
ago I would have just looked at the
rent-a-cop and gone the hell's the
matter with that guy and and and maybe
yelled something at him but that's not
and by the way that's what I'm told I'm
supposed to do by saying people
afterwards there were several choices
that I was given that was one of them I
sadly wait what were they what were they
saying you should do that I should call
you a check on what the guy who's been
abused who's being abused and just go
talk to him and go the [__] the matter
with that guy that guy's your you're
perfectly sane human being or a weird
job and you're looking for
I know you didn't cause a well and the
funny thing about that guy is that he
was just laughing at the guy which means
that that was the third time that it
wanted it right so but I turned into
white lady meat shield right and I throw
myself into the breach and I started
yelling at this old man I just yell at
him and I'm like and I'm swearing and
anything to reeling well let the
swearing begin I'm just wearing in the
whole show I just wearing a lot lately
but uh so I was like what the [__] is
your problem you're a piece of [__]
you're an [__] and its luggage is
heart in mind yet white yelling in his
safe and he's pointing a lot at him look
at your [__] stupid loaf of bread is
just a case and then so it when I'm I
did that for probably 15 to 30 seconds
on your Seng minute but I'm all right
the whole thing is maybe intimate in the
African followed him to his car Oh
anyway so he said to me um there's none
of your business it doesn't matter do
with you and I said it has everything to
do with me cuz is America and I'm an
American and you're an [__] or
something like that and then he says ha
America and I turn into a country music
song and I stiff-arm him oh man and I
push him and he just kind of say doesn't
fall down I'm 80 years old you bet you I
was waiting for you didn't ever call me
a [__] or a [__] or anything like that
clearly all of his anger his and people
with melanin right he's got some issues
all right um I was like I'm so like I
did so mad and I was like I can't
believe you did that and he was like you
just have any I was like it totally asst
and I'm just yelling at him as you watch
to his car as I walked to my car so this
is not the work of Captain America you
guys Captain America does not cry in his
car afterwards by the way that never
happens which evers go to so he so so
that what really sparked the physical
mission Thank pas America
thing like the dog thing about the
Constitution and the Declaration of
Independence and the ideals in the the
idea that we're all supposed to be going
forward to play online Changjo right are
you sure are you absolutely sure that he
was not saying ha America like that's
his superhero name like maybe a fish's a
I'm hoping to turn into somebody when he
said America don't you recognize what
they do you recognize me and you America
never got a successful is on the books
and America does a really different
surgeons that is a different character
Captain America stole it for me yeah
we'll look into that and so he does that
and your arm it just shot out yeah I
just I just reacted though I pushed him
right and it into his cart towards his
car no towards the towards Ross like
towards led the carts right right and um
and then I was just like did I just saw
him push an old man and then I literally
as he keeps talking to me I was like I
want to kick this guy to death and I was
like okay get it together get it
together and uh I just started I was
like and then it he wasn't responding to
me at all like I was not getting the
reaction I wanted right so I was like
and I'm like I could and and he's
probably the only person I could take an
80 year old dude at this point this is
the that that sort of soon yeah so yeah
I'm not the hero that story yes which
ironically is not even on the album it
is not on the album and it took me three
days to tell my husband oh my goodness
so you've got home and he was like did
you get the laundry to turn yeah
AMERICA AMERICA AMERICA right and I just
he was like was there actually he just
said so was there an immigration thing I
said there wasn't yeah and that the next
day I told a friend of mine before I
told my husband I was like I need to
talk to other people who are saying who
won't divorce me or hate me forever or
be disappointed me here's another this
is a this is a loaded question no what
do you do what do you think the
likelihood is that this guy feels more
comfortable saying this now than he
would have a year ago I think it's
entirely the with the general grabbing
in the and the and mud and the making
fun of a guy thing guys nothing just
came out like last week that that has
been basically aggregating all the hate
crime increases and yeah and I just
wanted I just watched a vid orig my ass
because I just watched a video last
night a shot in a I don't know like a
little food shop and it's a woman who's
buying food is being filmed and she's
yelling at whoever is holding the camera
but the caption on the video says I was
waiting to get my food I had my arm
around my girlfriend I kissed her on the
forehead twice and the woman is yelling
at this couple and saying why are you
doing that you're sexually harassing me
you're practically [__] you
prostitute like just going on and on and
on and she calls this woman a [__] and a
[__] and a [__] and the ugliest woman
she's ever seen and it keeps tickling or
a prostitute and like the people who are
filming her were very and calm yeah they
I mean initially they were like shut get
she came walking over and the guy was
like get the [__] back get the [__] away
from me she was like don't you talk to
me that like it was so but she did walk
away but don't you talk to me like
but then 27 reaming I'm sick correct
then she kept on yelling at them yelling
at them yelling at them and the guy was
like she was like I'm gonna call the
police and tell him that a prostitute
was about to [__] somebody in this and
the guys like please call the police I
would love for the police clear get the
police here meanwhile there's a guy
behind the counter doing nothing yeah
but finally more people come into the
shop and they're kind of so so now she
started to walk out so they're in the
shot of this guy she's still screaming
at them screaming at them screaming at
them and the people who have come in
don't know what to do and finally one of
the guys says I think you need to leave
oh but he has an accent on and she goes
shut the [__] up I'm an American you go
back to your country and he wasn't it
was he was like a French guy like it
wasn't like some crazy right now he
wasn't a Sikh and wearing a what girl
anyway don't understand even if what it
was right no of course but it was like I
just you knew that was she had it rare
with it I mean yeah right you know what
I mean and it was so she got I mean she
clearly wailing in different pots she
clearly has she's a fizzle full cauldron
of it clearly has mental issues yeah but
what this is that on top of that was
like like because as soon as I opened
his mouth she was all about how she was
an American need to go back to the
wherever the [__] he came from and you
know whatever and I was like it just was
so to me a demonstration of how we're
line has moved yeah mine is definitely
moving to be a line well there's a line
and it turns out i am the part of the
village that will show you where that
line is and paw america is the type
America wants to get in the face again I
am there are better ways to do it the
other the other suggestion i got was
somebody said you should just talk to
them go up to the person who sang the
horrible things and just say can you
hear what you're saying mmm can you hear
which I say of mirror for them right and
then I guess you're supposed to say it
until you bore them to death or
something I'm uncertain
like what that's going to do well here's
here's I'm not advocating for that but i
will say i do think in that situation
when somebody is that uh hi emotionally
if you come in really low emotionally
that can be very disarming to them right
it should help like because if you come
in as you did and go [__] you then it's
just like it escalate everybody raising
the bar i have lost my temper a couple
of times and it's less and less as as i
learned to deal with the fact that hey
zip it but I once lost my temper with a
woman who was wearing a bus uniform and
I grabbed her I mean literally another
great story of where I've because I was
not anywhere near in the right on this
thing and the woman who was dressed as a
bus driver the bus and foot inside with
halloween and halloween see that when I
what I will say is that the only reason
i say she's a bus drivers because she
knew how to deal with insanity probably
does she still had right I knew what to
do with crazy over here and I had her
brother shirt and she goes what are you
doing you're not gonna hit me and I let
go over and I was like you're correct i
am not going to hate you I have to be on
stage in 15 minutes I think I think
because the times we live in and more
anger just being around I mean it's just
it's powerful you can it's we know it's
out there you see these videos and stuff
I just saw like one of the compilation
of that kind of thing of yeah people
going off and you know xenophobic racist
stuff and I don't know how you feel but
I get such a visceral reaction to those
things yeah like and I can't stop like I
can't stop once I start watching some I
my thing is um I think with our egos
today me just yawned so big I'm very
captivating that's where I think I've
been up both backward I think I think
what it comes down to is really having I
think people are for the first time I
really having to think about what it
means to de-escalate a situation I know
yeah right because we all know that you
could walk away but there are too many
situations now we
you don't want to want like you don't
necessarily want to walk away you should
not walk away right because you know
that my pic that there could be good
done by not walking away if it was the
right answer I could then of forces you
to figure out what is that process to
de-escalate something now the
interesting thing is I write a lot of
you know public transit am on the bus a
lot and I've had those moments where
somebody comes on they have charged
energy maybe they're yelling that could
be mentally ill they could just be angry
and I've always thought about like what
is like you said like you ask them a
question can you hear what you're saying
what is something that would be so
disarming bring that female right that
they don't expect and you say oh that
could help the other thing though is
that you never know if it's going to go
the other way which is that they turn it
on so long because this guy you said
this guy didn't necessarily engage back
and that actually flared you up a little
bit more because it can go that way too
so it's so hard to know it's a win-win
baby if by winning you mean losing yeah
so but that's the thing it's like how do
you call how do you de-escalate and ask
them what they're working on the pink is
how are you I think so we all know that
that's the biggest problem with police
eh whatever however they're being
trained but I think that they have
feelings and that should mean classes
like someone should teach that what you
want to take it right if you don't say a
word to me this is the police thing it's
like if you say a word back to me I'm
gonna go so high on you right like that
video I'm sure you saw the thing where
the the lady called the cops hehe
neighbor grabbed the kid and then the
cops showed up and arrested the lady and
the kid and did nothing or the guy who
and Brett I'd grabbed a kid in the first
place yeah it was all about the cop
being like [__] you you can't talk back
to me you know it was like what do you
do
Wayne I called you and she got arrested
no yeah I i I've had I mean again living
in downtown like I've had you learn how
to that energy starts coming at you
aggressive energy someone yelling
shouting which is often in downtown I've
had to have those moments where I try to
be very calm like just really try to put
out like a calm energy and I've had it
happen a couple times where a street
person will take that in and they've
done quiet I've had a conversation but
it because it's all you're talking about
energy vampires are you in love with a
vampire my therapist wrote that but
that's that that's I you know I think
everyone's starting to have to figure
out and think more about like how do you
deal with your honor I'd forgotten about
that blessed thing until just now but
that is I mean I loved out she really be
escalated it ever is she was like hey
like she made eye contact there's like
you're not gonna hit me right we were
just at the same pump at the gas station
right keep it together I've always
thought were they that but what if you
asked like magic jack he just starts
listing off all these things where she's
like a tag Imperial oh my god welcome to
this is my clothes in the dryer what the
[__] is wrong right here's a quarter
please it used to happen I'd used to
having like once or twice a year and
then it hasn't happened in probably four
years and then previously was like two
years I'm getting better you guys but
I'm still this isn't great this is not
great but not when you're losing your
[__] but i also i also think there's a
different thing now like because my
thing is if i am around something where
there's like because this was not true
when i was younger but now there's like
aggression or whatever right I'm like
I'm going to avoid this yeah and I'll
come back is why frankly the rat is no
rien to become involved rattus spray but
now and i have not had to deal with this
at all yet but i do wonder like what if
i'm gonna
tuition where somebody is saying go the
[__] back to your country right then
what like not that we're not something
I'm going to just go you know what I
don't need to get involved in that yeah
I've heard I would be like I am para
merica you could be polymeric yes I've
heard the reaction specifically to that
being said if you're the third party and
stepping in and saying we don't say that
here but which it Lord brings it back to
like yeah this is my this is my country
as well yeah did then in my country we
don't say this yeah you are the one
who's wrong you know you're the one
who's not acting like an American right
it's like taking it is kind of taking
back that whole i'm an american thing
yeah no no no I'm the it sometimes are
failing right side of America right it's
it right now you're being the wrong kind
of a man it sounds cheesy it sounds
corny it sounds all these things but I
don't care right I really don't care
what you think I'm lame for doing it
Soviet right all right but I'm not going
to stand by and and and and watch it I
genuinely love the ideals I genuinely
love the idea I want the ideals to be
true and I know that they aren't I know
that we drop the ball all the time but
it's the dream that she thought it's the
dress that I it's the dream that keeps
just trying to any of it right and I
also yeah you know well whatever i'm
only interest all right look feels like
it feels like it can still be good to
take a break you just be escalated
europe David and I'm got enough let's
just take a quick break and then we'll
be back with a segment on the show we
like to call-- parting your shots and
then Jamie will take a map
[Music]
we are back you are listening to the
long shot it is a podcast I'm your host
my name is Sean Conroy we are at a
segment in the show that we like to call
parting shots and I guess today because
we're in parting shots let's start with
me uh oh hey and this is this is stupid
this is like such a dumb probably a
thing more that will end up being a
stand-up did or whatever or maybe not
but I was watching TV yesterday hate and
I saw a commercial which I've probably
seen hundreds of times before but it
just hit me really hard all of a sudden
which was its two women and one of those
looking at her phone and she goes oh and
the other one goes what's wrong and she
goes I just got charged for credit
monitoring again one of those
commercials like yeah you know credit
monitoring their free credit check com I
was like who the [__] is sitting around
checking their credit all the time and
getting charged for it and going on yeah
I can like what a stupid premise for a
commercial I feel like there's a totally
different way to get it like yeah I
don't know if I've ever checked my thing
when 99% people know my credit is bad
yeah it's like why did I look at it I
don't have good credit hey Bob you want
to see those crime scene photos again
boy that was a brutal murder well and
but it's because they sell for four
bucks a month or something like that
they can get old people to pay them you
like we'll keep track here it's your
it's your identity theft and your credit
rating and your I guess there was a time
also when people were much more
attentive to that type of thing Frank
like my mother always talks about one of
her law partners who because she'll say
to me like how much is being taken out
of your paycheck for state taxes or
whatever I'm like the function I know
what boxes if you'd like then she's like
Larry
a new to the scent on every paycheck
what was being taken out for this what
was being taken you know so there was a
time of people really paid attention to
that stuff and maybe there still are
people like that but I don't know any of
them probably should be like I guess so
many instances of like getting shorted
on pay but you're like a direct deposit
like who's like I don't know also for me
it's kind of what you're saying which is
like I'm [__] I know I'm fun so why do
I want to know that more than I already
know that you know there's because there
is no longer generation that uses
checkbooks right that was I always
remember seeing my mom and my aunt like
my shadow like Allison actually yeah but
I do not balance my children you could
go online and for you what your balance
is lies I'm just saying I don't balance
my checkbook okay like what my answer is
like oh you just do the online banking
and so you like I don't know what I
don't have a buddy okay I have no money
you know uh check cashing places are
great no no the first year I lived here
I had one until Jennifer McClain whose
friend of mine was my roommate she was
like Jesus get a bank account okay so
why someone had to say it out loud
that's Illinois so much worse they're so
[__] up I mean way my grandfather used
to call them banks for poor people
because yeah like that's all I rip off
oh yeah thank you for sent here in 11
it's one of the fundamental [__]
flaws of this country that anything
money-related that they will go the
hardest after the people who don't revel
in yeah that was is the same flaw like
of like your your check bounced because
you don't have enough money in your
account once i'm going to charge you
thirty dollars because you don't have
mud right it's the company store you
know right where's our face makeover
happen
hi lady okay thanks make over half their
money on late fees and if you feel ya
it's all profit for them to charge
people for every little [__] thing I
can't stand anybody who works for a bank
or ever has all the line of which let's
go next to Amber don't look many year
baby wow I've been fresh uh oh my boring
shot is nice and light marry after what
we've been talking about weirdo weapons
is that correct they were kind enough
Jaime's friends they sent me in the mail
which was such a delightful surprise the
bond me socks but they were talking
around the episode I was like I want
bond results so they mailed me some bomb
me socks with a handwritten oh and it
was such a sweet treat what a fun thing
and a kind thing gonna be sandwich so
yeah like actually it's just um I think
it's called band my god me I'm [__]
that's what I'd love to go to I love I
love to go to classes in guns no no I
always go up and I can I get a band my
it just thought that have little
pictures of bondages guys um so support
them they've got great pins and awesome
stuff and they're cool what are they
called weirdo weapons and where's their
website I think it's weird of weapons
calm but i also found them on Instagram
really easily and I posted a picture of
my boundary sucks and I tags a minute so
you could find them through that how how
how close of friends are they to jail
they're Jamie's best friend both of them
yeah they are I i will say Eric in
particular is them as far in cold front
no but they're both equally that's right
okay do you traditionally have a great
deal of best friends it just recently
came up salmon
with him like sacking the order of who's
closer friends close friends when I was
I spent the whole episode they're both
great but he just did he's gotten
someone join the last couple years of
just sending things to people in the
mail it's really it wasn't yes and who
gets anything in the mail it's really
exciting so excited yeah it was so
freeing but yeah just actively thinking
about people that might want to get
something in the mail whether somebody
made or not like every morsel I'll just
get like a new PIN Denis man yeah fan
yeah we shall send the same things more
my dad wants cash and by the way so long
sub people doesn't send your addresses
to us wait maybe one day we'll get our
sit together send me somebody sure sure
be at add you can have a spreadsheet is
I already have a job Amy yes and this
your your social security number any
info any info on you that you feel might
be relevant picture your dog picture
yourself in a boat on a river Joe
parting shot I had a bond my sandwich oh
no did I go wrong yeah picking on me oh
I believe its bond hopping me ya bah yes
Bob no all right I had one yesterday
it's delicious I love it so good um
hungry now they're very good let's see
what else uh I love Sean's coconut
candle in the bathroom I sweet huh
chocolates variants care and I know
expansion so beautiful in there i also
broke your screen door oh I thought I I
thought I just went I hit that Valley
not on the rails
confession time yeah that's like some
doing the fake get out the old wrench
set and ask him about his shoes what
issues that he has over there that could
be your check there yea or no say
something about say something about the
color of the ceiling its long-term like
it easy to let go talk about the wires
on the table that's it that's it Wow
asking about this you coming everyone
there's a great new caramel pretzel
donut at dunkin donuts Jesus Oh Sean
likes it when i plug Duncan Dennis all
right jack and the parting shot pretty
shot um thank you for having me on the
longshots course yeah gathering of
like-minded individuals there's no time
like the present to start embarrassing
myself with things that just happened
and I will so hopefully turn into
stand-up comedy better punch line and
you're you're you know you're going
after yourself that's yeah and that's
the best really it's I'm killing it you
guys yeah yeah yeah I'm really doing
well and it's hard to be me I'll be in
Winnipeg when this goes up and i'm going
to Peoria next time so things you know I
think it's your it's me how it sounds
like a punch line fury is a punch like
an old vaudeville joke I don't think I
think there's a statue of Richard Pryor
in town because he's from Peoria oh hell
yeah yeah which is weird but Jackie you
are a successful tour in common Miami
yes traveling the country yes things are
going well I do I'm just curious azaab
obviously have some of what we were
talking before tours downtown
thank you down as predatory so it's
cooking for angry home um I'm just
curious like if you are you seeing
feeling noticing anything out there
wherever you're playing in the club's oh
cuz of the vibe just go to the vibe yeah
just wondering what it's like for a road
comic recently and that was the first
place out of town that I've been yes
since the election that wasn't opening
up for Bamford so opening up for Bamford
it's the it's a different crowd of the
pile of marshmallows right so it's fine
and then of my people also when they
figure nervous just imagine they're a
pilot actually what a great fun thing be
the person opens for that person oh yeah
like you get this amazing crowd that are
available they want to hear what weirdo
thing you're doing and there's no
pressure on you because you're not the
one I don't depress yeah I phone but
it's pretty nice and so what else what
else and then yeah so the first time I
went and did you know my own headline
stuff out of off of the election was in
Spokane like two weeks ago three weeks
ago because i did a nerd cruise after
that and I didn't do anything political
on that because we're on the ocean is
like a hostage situation I didn't want
to work you out without of the coastal
bubble where we were in mech we were on
mega any state jurisdiction right right
it was no politics right there was it
felt like let's give these people it was
like the week of the election I was at
the comedy works in Denver and so
juggles like if President knobjob if
elected right and then I have to go to
Denver know and I come remember knob
jobs and from when you were a lot of
what not the actual not but anyway so
the and then and then uh so yeah the I
said something sexual on the last
episode will come out in two weeks
everybody got very people did ten sorry
she said but they're like oh [__] you
guys well we don't endure an 11 year old
that's good stuff I'm talking about
consensual oral sex between a man and
soup it all says that will pay off so I
do i do people to go back i'll be there
weeks or I've chosen not to do political
stuff it was it was the week of the
election which I feel like everyone
needed to not have to deal with me and
it really came to a show to get away for
an hour and a half and then and then the
joco Cruz was with something else and
then so I spoke am though uh and was
this book is began in the middle of
Washington which once you get out of
Seattle it can get super conservative
yeah and so there were some people I you
know I opened my set with something
political and I just talking about it in
general and like three different tables
right yes you're gonna do it like some
woman said go for it like any audience
nice and there was like handlebar
mustache in the front row just folded
his arms and a couple of people got a
little tense but the greatest thing
about stand-up comedy crowds everywhere
is that they never know what they're
going to see they are to some extent the
most open-minded people in the world
because they're like oh am I going to
watch uh you know Nick DiPaolo [__] on
women for an hour and it's going to be
funny maybe right or am I gonna watch
Maria Bamford you know talk about mental
illness and bananas and your a and so
because nobody YouTube Google's the
comic that makes them by default some of
the most open-minded people there like
that's not funny for me but nice adjust
their so there were some of that energy
in the audience but I was like at one
point some guy just glared at me and I
said dude I don't care I I will going to
walk to my car so you can be all mad as
you want so it feels like that I saw
there was a story that just came out
about how at this point even some Trump
supporters are like hey can you cool it
on the tweeting you know like even
Trump's I feel like you can still
connect with some Trump supporters at
this point from sheer exhaustion of like
that guy that you voted for
look we all can see that he's insane an
incompetent man you know reality TV
right did you see the not to pro
hoity-toity fake news at you but did you
see the nicholas kristof article in
today's times I'm gonna pick up this
name you've dropped he interviewed some
Trump voters very specifically people
who one of them worked for a battered
women's shelter another guy had gone
through a vocational training program to
retrain him so that he could get a new
job and now I had a job and was
supporting his kids in college these are
all programs that Trump is cutting
completely getting rid of and these
people are saying they voted for Trump
and they're saying I thought he would
you know I thought me laughter other you
in how to do this right yeah but I would
still vote for him again oh really jack
well because people hate being wrong
that's nice the psychological buddy
right right yeah it makes I'm used to it
I'm so you thought am I gonna plow my
children all right you've never been
wrong in saying you're lying it's all
the thing is is that it yeah i don't i
don't know worse in that race i mean if
you think I'm wrong it's and you can
probably have I prob very likely and I
my self-esteem is not like I get lost on
numbered grid streets in New York City
right I have no sense of direction so
how how am I gonna say oh you're
probably I'm like oh well why should you
tell me I'm wrong yeah you are saying it
to me 1 million less times than I have
said to myself if you have facts right
you got all kinds of I'm just beating
myself up over here that might be a way
of approaching at maybe some stand-up in
that way of like a stand-up can say to
an audience like hey we all get fooled
like we all get I've been fooled I've
been tray I'm een yeah the vulnerability
of a stand-up as far as self-examination
I think that's where you can build a
common ground to like I'm not saying if
you can write that joke that Joe could
could build a bridge right right okay so
you're not and that sound 2020 as well
but it goes cristoforos yeah yeah
because it's one thing to say you're an
idiot salsa then you say I've been an
idiot too I mean I'm not that's not
going to be the one thing I used to
define you but if you if you're not
looking at where we're at with this guy
and still at this point and not seeing
think there's a lot of people are still
not I know I know but but more stories
are coming out of people who literally
wants shame on you fool me twice won't
get fooled again but the things are just
starting to happen enough changes
executive orders all these things that
are just starting to affect some people
or the people that it is going to affect
are saying oh this is going to hurt me
or impair my life in some way what's
just starting what what amazes me and
then that will get to you in a second
Jamie so be ready what amazes me is and
this is just my personal opinion looking
at the decisions this president has made
in every respect whether it's hiring
people whether it's how to speak to
other countries that whether its
executive orders every single decision
if I looked at a list and I said what's
the worst possible decision he could
make that is
he has made right and I know that's mean
it's my personal thing but I really feel
like he has it's amazing it's like know
what is the worst you know it's like if
you go to Baskin Robbins and you get the
peach cobbler ice cream like what was
the worst sorry didn't know bubblegum I
as an adult as an adult right yeah what
is the worst possible decision you could
be my dad who's 79 years old and by no
stretch of the imagination illiberal
there a mosque just opened about a year
ago in South Milwaukee Wisconsin and so
I called him up and I was like how are
people handling them up it's an old
Catholic Church that's been
deconsecrated and now it's a mosque in a
school and my dad really he was like
well most people get it just means a
place going to be crawling with laughs
Muslims in a hundred years oh my god
that's exactly the point that is exactly
the point it's America right it doesn't
camp your any unless they Institute as
they have in many parts of the country
now Michigan and other places unless the
Institute Shariah law my right well and
my thing is like you're gonna go to a
picnic and you're going to have to ask
some lady if there's mint in the trailer
salad that's going to be the whole
that's how your life is going to change
right someone's gonna wear a hat and
you're gonna have to say it's their
mental is and then you're going to eat
it anyway because it's jello salad why
did you get the bubble gum ice cream why
did you vote for the bubble gum ice
cream again Jamie parting shots I'll
shift gears a little bit thank God you
mentioned then at me or amber amber I'm
not being here to make friends I get
your dance class which is like that kind
of reality show troppo and last night I
wants to show that maybe the match on
this program the Great British Bake Off
the Great British Bake Off is the
greatest thing so good the only thing I
want to go no okay good I watched two
episodes of times and perfect shifting
of gears service yeah it's like a
fountain it's so soothing to pile of
marshmallows man if they are
like a comedy audience there's like no
one has ever had that's the things like
everybody here a little bit but other
people are like now it's just a baking
just iveco i love it when that woman
says it's just a cake seriously though
every stall room and all the carrier
it's all like they're intentionally
making it a mood stabilizer because they
will pan too just like a sheep walk yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's our segue that not
a little for me I Japan it's a bunch of
sheets the most soothing show of all
time did you just have the Sheep say nay
I did a man okay that works that ago but
also i just love like jump on him so
fast i was gonna say shipped on that
like like what satan as you say over
shes owning that with a has been in a
very soothing way so the people in
britain like their relationship of
generals it's so different like everyone
knows what a swiss roll is everyone has
a family recipe that show i don't know
if that is across all of rain let me
just tell you something though i don't
want to eat any of the food that's a
timely manner I was like also a fiddle
and dill like this kids like no I just
get me a piece of well my old family
recipe calls for four fatal than three
little to make a swift that way
Blackalicious the murder of these weird
desserts and they all have like it'll be
a trifle and it'll be this man try me
you're like all I can think of a classic
French was like a with a German twist
remember when Rachel made that half
trifle half shepherd's pie in friends
when we made a Oh mom used to say is
never put mint in the jello anyway
there's great show but it I struggling
another wasn't that's pretty how many
sees another at least 30 I alright
there's only three available in America
but there's been like I don't know what
I was watching it was on that place and
I watched two episodes though just like
is the opposite of American reality of
just like yeah this is a competition
everyone's against each other but like
they're all seemed supportive and
friendly on that note I went this week
to the television Academy to see a panel
discussion was even really a panel I
don't I guess it was
but it was a guy named Mike Darnell who
do you know who is you know what he's
like Candido he's the does he respond
for yeah he's responsible for all of it
everything he's like easy easy tiny
odd-looking man so weird living like I
was way in the back like was a huge
theater and I was way back but you could
see there's a name and a face that we
just put on this abomination looks like
a dark elf he really funny can't be more
than five feet tall yeah yeah he's got
this big like curly hair and a voice
where he could be please baby I don't
know he's like and then in nineteen like
he has like a weird voice like a bad guy
he's a regarded by the Hitler he's
clearly a genius in terms of
manipulation of humanity correct fair
enough and so he created like temptation
island he created Joe Millionaire
created a swan he created the american
version of american idol was like kind
of the biggest thing he ever did but
what was super weird about because
you're talking about how everybody's
like friendly and getting along clearly
that's not the idea on these american
reality shows fight with each other and
and you know part of me was like [__]
this guy like whatever but he actually
even said in the middle of his prison
he's being interviewed by Andy Cohen
from Bravo mm-hmm and because they are
now making a new version of love
connection I'm just going to come back
but anyway he said you know everybody
complains about reality shows like who
cares about reality they think it's
about reality and it's different from
scripted it's not different from
scripted reality shows are just as
scripted as no Tristan and and in my
head I'm going yet except you don't have
to pay anybody I do it yeah you got
editor some editors right who are paid
way less than yeah what a writing
cynical don't know that oh it's like
Jeff's parents they're smart people he's
a surgeon and when they came here they
were like close friend car
could we eat at kitchen nightmare and
we're like it's not a real restaurant
not a thing that we can go to it's a
reality show by the way that guy has
five shows than this guy has created I
like him Gordon Ramsay I worked on one
my big fat obnoxious fiance which was on
no no I was saying go around corners
live shows yeah that Dharma know your
nails one one of his shows was my big
fat obnoxious yeah yeah it sounds funny
but what was that was super [__] up
about it was I was there with a friend
of mine who's a producer and so he kind
of his playing both sides but everybody
was there to see their [__] hero Mike
Darnell and so he would say these really
[__] up things about how he
manipulated people into this great
moment on this show and we didn't tell
this guy this think her in a while she
got too many people would be like oh it
was also her ass feeling yes yuck but I
did stay for the whole thing also I
would get a jump start to like a jog
that can run really fast I guess we'd
all stay and watch it that's right
there's no no I watched the baking show
with a three-legged dog with us really
yeah really good dogs nothing fancy
about that you've watched it with a
three-legged dog that's actually I've
actually a country song i watch the
bacon show with us very like a dog I
don't know remember that old joke about
the three-legged peg oh it's a good oh
I'm all right so a farmer in a Salesman
oats really like it sort of like your
family what is it all so it'sit's and I
will cut to the chase on this and now
the v day long but we have lives to lead
but the thing is but it's a three-legged
pig salesman shows up at the farm the
farmer has a three-legged figs salesman
says when how'd you get this a
three-legged pig and the three and the
farmers like well tell you about this
big is you know our house almost burned
down this pig woke us up and got us out
of the house saved their lives he was
like oh did he lose the leg during the
house brings like no no no
I didn't have it was like how do you
lose it well tell you about this pick is
they save my daughter from the down the
well came and got it like others like a
quadrant right so at the end of it the
sales was like the hell with the thrill
out why is why do you want it lose its
wing and it goes ah pig that great you
can't eat it all at once the longest
longest joke in the world no angel it's
a shaky pictures you can go on forever
and but it is a great job tell you about
this big we couldn't get on the wireless
nobody could remember what the password
wire oh my god he backed up her computer
we thought everything was gone turns out
the pig put everything in the cloud I
had no idea of my credit score babe came
in 100 i was getting charged twice a
month for credit score change pic selfie
of ringtones of a credit report.com
Christmas last year my Pig gave me this
coconut scandalous beautiful he's just
thoughtful to basket like a beachy good
G so I think I also this friday i have
my first show i'm producing at the
improv so come to that if you don't
something who's on the show I don't know
yet hey everyone could be everyone you
you get to decide who's on the show
though right I do okay I just for a
second I thought maybe like he's like
you're producing a show with the improv
gets to book all of you know what a
queer I shows ya and even when I'm not
working that I might find a way to wait
till last minute to put things together
so its Aisha Tyler and I assume and
Bamford she's gonna and who else but
flam tasia his name the show today just
nice work bringing people into the house
is on the show there's a bunch of
dancing for i am i'm talking about
having a puppet and talking about it
are you moving your lips while your
today me are you still talking yourself
in there I actually have the person that
Ben knows how to work with puppets and
so Jackie do you have a pearl of wisdom
they're done pearl I don't know why came
out there that i'm having going a good
one yeah the place cut that you don't
talk about pearls of wisdom they don't
talk about nuggets ability well
certainly not feeling well I guess it
just like a weird there's a place such
as a doing it for several fires that he
finally comes okay tomorrow yeah have a
conversation to whether the little black
balls is called in a drink go ova
there's a boba place called pearls right
on the corner ask her for a bucket me
too i think that is the new thing i like
a boba wisdom okay some sort of guiding
principle happy okay yes that you can
impart to us and our listeners i think
it is then got to be the bow bow there's
no there's no hitting I think you did
you you clarified the sauce and then you
and then you money I'm owed some money
of strategy where pearl of wisdom is
great boba of women would make me go
what the [__] is wrong with this guy hey
I'm gonna need a really big strong
should really get this wisdom going um I
met this woman who a producer lady who
accidentally told people that she had
had a girlfriend at one point and now
she's engaged to a man and so there's
been some sort of weird hoopla in her
world about her being bisexual and um
and she was like I can't believe people
are all they're like wow could you be
with this guy and I'm like what's
happening and because i read a great
science fiction book it was about and
the greatest line is lois mcmaster
bujold i think was called shards of
honor there you go it was a space opera
and are similar essentially han Solo
space by my house space operas are tough
because sound doesn't travel in know
[Music]
wow that was like you know I'm gonna
hear you hit a high speed never going to
break that glass on here so also call
them spa / ospakar but that sounds like
they're soaking in hot water I gotta get
a massage at their house show anyway so
the the the best definition of bisexual
when you're in a relationship that I've
heard in ever is if somebody said to the
one of the characters he's you know he's
bisexual and she said sure but he's
monogamous right now with me randa and
that was the whole and so that is the
nugget of wisdom that I that I was able
to impart to someone else this week
nugget and we went back to nugget above
all it's okay for you to do it because
you understood its prospects that are
putting it back down it's just still
done good that is still deny get uh
that's great you so you're gonna be
where this week i mean i'm in Winnipeg
this week area megaria next week yeah
then I'm doing a benefit in Minneapolis
for the Children's crisis center which
is when you're when you're what you're
going to kill your kids there's crisis
center in most cities and there's one of
minneapolis called the crisis nursery
and if you think you're going to kill
your kids the graceless nurses like hey
we'll take them we'll take it for a day
or a couple hours or until you get your
want you let's go take a nap it can be
frustrating so yeah so every so I'm
doing that benefit in Minneapolis april
nineteen things greatly yeah well thank
you for being here and by the way do you
do a benefit of do a sort of benefit
after shoving an 80 year old man I triad
it's an amendment about a living a man
like I ever change your baby either I'm
not doing it she's not doing a benefit
for the crisis old a child yeah right
elderly people what a Chad Daniels is a
great joke about how his grandmother is
a racist and someone said well you know
she was raised differently and he goes
yeah but she's raised now right right
she's already raised on Rashida dope
okay folks this has been the long shot
okay we plug dickies podcast real quick
sure to great podcast or forest
for us which you've been doing 11 years
alone flora something that doesn't make
any money you guys get in there yeah
we're there oh yeah you have an amazing
fan base yeah yeah so the Rangers yeah
it's a that's they call themselves
ranger fedora I love it and then i'm
also a big fan of that jackie has
another podcast with Laurie Kilmartin
yeah Jackie and Laurie show where we
literally just [__] about stand-up
comedy yeah that's for you mark you were
I am a fan or a stand-up and you want to
hear two veterans who know everything
about the business and make it really
funny to talk about and and complain
about justifiably every time funny I I
know we have to finish it but now that
you brought up Lori I want to say one
more thing because I saw Lori on a plane
we were both flying to New York at the
same time and she was flying just to do
a show out there I was flying to go to a
football game because I have my
priorities um but I said to her because
I've had a really hard time in the last
few years as I've been working trying to
do stand-up after work all right after
the writing so hard and all your energy
yeah and I and I go Lori how do you get
up so much like whatever like yeah how
are you able to and she goes oh I
couldn't not because that's the only
part of my day I feel like this is mine
yeah Wow and I was like [__] yeah that's
true you know yeah thats that is true
that nugget right there talk about a
nugget bo bo bo shows a ten-year-old son
yeah and she that she is the main
caretaker of and then um and her mom
just moved in with her about a year ago
79 year old mom and he has a special on
seeso right now special auntie saw 45
jokes want my dad dad she accidentally
live tweeted her father's death and they
turned and she turned into 45 jokes
about it uh-huh and it's it's amazing
she's an amazing comic if you guys have
seen so or amazon prime you can get to
see so for free but I also you know it
just she just blows me away because like
I remember being at a club with her a
couple years ago and I won't say the
name of a club but let's go there no no
it's like there's improv
there is an improv that goes on there
welcome it's got a confusing name anyway
we were doing a show there thanks to
jamie mm-hmm and it was one of those
shows where they go and I can't even
remember who it was but it was like
please allow oh somebody nine comic x
yeah and it was a ten o'clock show on a
weeknight and we both had spots at like
you know ten oh five and 10 20 and comic
ex showed up and went on for an hour and
so we were in this booth in the back and
Laurie was literally like sleeping off
whose comic acts I can't remember I I
think I might know it is i'll tell you
afterward i did one of those headline
weekends that you gave me and they said
hate Dean cooks been showing up the
lungs I said you can't go up my truck
and the sound I said why I don't know
how to say no to dane cook and I said I
do i do I do he shows up all that have
been an issue for ya and end up being an
issue but um but I guess he had been and
he didn't it it was a it was there was a
couple of times when he had gone long
during a weekend but somebody then did
talk to him and say hey man it's cool
you're famous let's do something but
don't be cool though yeah be cool I mean
that's all anyone ever I mean because
like I remember Judd Apatow um Jay Leno
and J Lana both wanted guess that's on
some show and I was like well I don't
actually know how to say no to them and
so and they were both greater than the
lighting guy was like I do I just like
kinda like a perfect to you know the
only thing I did was I put a bateau
before leno so that he wouldn't run the
light because he wanted to impress wow I
look so worried so he J and I and I like
should have to stand up a lot quite
honestly but I was like no no I booked
this [__] thing so people need to get
up and have their lives and I didn't
kill Martin was on that one too Laurie
Kilmartin oh great yeah in our pods
pretty fun alright well this has been
quite an adventure yes we made it and we
will see you next time on a long shot at
this 300th episode hey is that next two
weeks from now
nexim lashawn's ya see it oh yeah Jamie
at Jamie flam calm and Jamie will give
you all the info about where to go are
you a child to rise just the other day
he came to the world and we give you
away but they were planes to catch bills
to pay you learn to walk while a walk
away for past present and future
episodes of the launch a podcast please
visit the longshot podcast.com
[Music]
when you're coming home data don't know
when but we will get together there you
know you'll have a good time man
[Music]
you